out to a couple of developing stories
from Russia and Ukraine we want to tell
you about let's start with new signs
from Moscow that it's now open to talk
said could lead to a prisoner exchange
involving jailed Wall Street reporter
Evan gerskovich he has been accused of
Espionage by Russia charges he denies
Remy inocencio has the latest from
London on this Ramy good morning to you
Gail good morning that's right a sliver
of Hope could be in the form of a
prisoner swap exchange for a Russian
held in detention since 2021 in the
United States and accused of cyber crime
and this possibility came up after
31-year-old Evan gershkovich was visited
by U.S ambassador to Russia Lynn Tracy
on Monday now that same day Russian
citizen Vladimir do naive received a
visit from Russian Consular services in
the state of Ohio and the timing made
Russia Watchers think that potentially a
swap could be in the works a Kremlin
spokesman Dimitri peskov also on Monday
did admit there have been certain
contacts on the subject but added we
don't want them to be discussed in
public and they must be carried out and
continue in complete silence now there
is precedent for U.S Russian prisoner
swaps the most recent of course being
WNBA basketball star Brittany Greiner
she was arrested on drug charges and
swapped in December for Victor bout who
is an Infamous weapons dealer
prior to that it was in 1986 with
American journalist Nicholas danloff he
was exchanged for events Soviet Union
employee of the United Nations charged
with Espionage for now gershkovic is set
to stay in Russia's Infamous lefertova
prison until at least August 30th the
U.S state Department for its part had no
comment on any prisoner exchange saying
only that it expected Russia to continue
to allow access to gershkovich Tony
all right Ramey thank you very much